a non-profit that offers showers to the  homeless is setting up in the valley  it's going to be over at the center on  maryland parkway in lewes it is also  mobile the group behind the showers is  called clean the world it is being  partially paid for by caesars and clark  county county commissioner tick sager  bloom says offering a shower is a first  step to more help well it's as i said  first off just the human dignity of  getting a shower  everybody should be entitled to that but  also if we can attract homeless to come  to these  facilities then we can try to offer  other services and hopefully start to  get them back into society  and the other goal is that the showers  will also help stop the spread of  hygiene related illnesses including  covet 19.